[Musica]
buonasera sogno utopia utopia o il sogno
qual è la differenza domanda facile o
difficile
la differenza è molto sottile e per
comprenderla al meglio dobbiamo
scomodare aspetti linguistici e
filosofici utopia deriva dal greco e
significa non luogo
nessun luogo la filosofia con un gioco
di parole dallo stesso suono accostato
il significato di buon luogo luogo
felice ecco allora che il significato di
utopia del dizionario è un'illusione
un progetto una speranza irrealizzabili
e invece sogni anche sogni deriva dal
greco e significa una fantasia
un'illusione
l'immaginazione di cose irrealizzabili
dette così sembrano praticamente la
stessa cosa ma allora perché si parla
sempre di realizzare sogni e mai di
rendere realtà utopie
forse perché non sono proprio la stessa
cosa
i sogni sono molto più vicini a noi
delle utopie ai sogni tutti in fondo in
fondo
attribuiamo una chance di realizzazione
all'utopia invece no ma provate a
pensare se un sogno realizzato né
attirasse un altro realizzato e se una
serie di sogni realizzati portasse a
rendere realtà un'utopia
magari per strade che non avevamo
neppure immaginato
io francesco abbiamo tanti sogni grandi
sogni e ogni giorno lavoriamo per alzare
sempre di più l'asticella e realizzarne
sempre di più in questo modo abbiamo
scoperto che i sogni sono facilmente
realizzabili ma sono le utopie quelle
che cambiano la vita delle persone e
cambiano
ma adesso abbiamo parlato di sogni e
utopie ma prima serve un'abilità
fondamentale la capacità di sognare
quando siamo bambini è tutto semplice ci
viene naturale non distinguiamo molti
sogni dalla realtà ma da adulti invece
da adulti invece quando è che noi adulti
abbiamo smesso di sognare
ve lo ricordate il momento preciso quel
preciso istante nella vostra linea
spazio temporale in cui avete chiuso a
chiave il cassetto quello dei sogni
perché là fuori
il mondo vero viene clamav a avrà a gran
voce e vi obbligava a inserirmi nei suoi
perversi meccanismi preconfezionati
difficile ricordarlo vero quel momento
sono però molto sicuro anzi sono certo
che vi cosa vi ricordiate con estrema
esattezza il periodo della vita
successivo a quel momento il primo della
vita in cui siete diventati adulti e
sono pronto anche a scommettere che
appena avete smesso di sognare tutto
siccome rapidamente ingrigito però voi
avete messo la testa a posto
avete trovato la vostra strada
ognuno di voi ha cercato di trovare il
suo posto nel mondo e di adattarsi non è
così lo so benissimo che così perché ci
sono passato anche io ma se ci
riflettete bene
qualcosa non torna sì perché in passato
forse anche voi avevate avuto dei
campanelli di allarme ma prontamente
avete soffocati quasi come se fossero
dei diavoli tentatori che stavano
cercando di portarli via dalla vostra
stretta strada e così avete cominciato
ad accettare il mondo per cui mi si
presentava anche se magari non vi
piaceva affatto e avete iniziato a
pensare ma in fondo a chi importa dei
miei sogni
il mondo è sempre andato avanti
benissimo anche senza di me e alla fine
vi siete messi da parte sapendo
benissimo che da quella parte ne avresti
trovati tanti come voi tutti i fedeli
allo stesso credo alla stessa
convinzione meglio spegnersi insieme che
brillare da soli
studia perché devi lavorare lavora
perché devi pagare le tasse e paga le
tasse perché devi vivere bene forse
sarebbe meglio dire sopravvivere
chi verrà da sorridere magari ma questo
e nient'altro che il paradigma di vita
che tutti quelli che si sono dimessi da
parte hanno accettato già sognare
non c'è più tempo per sognare
figuriamoci per credere in un utopia ma
credeteci voi e le utopie
lasciatemi stare lasciatemi al buio i
bambini dovrebbero essere contenti di
andare a scuola
la sera prima di andare a dormire non
dovrebbero veder l'ora di tornare a
scuola perché lì è il posto migliore
dove possono essere dove possono
crescere migliorare esprimersi al meglio
e costruire il loro futuro di qualità a
scuola dovrebbe essere valorizzato il
gioco libero perché tramite il gioco
libero i bambini possono essere
fantasiosi creativi e usare l'arma più
potente che hanno il compito di noi
educatori e importantissimo in ogni
momento che abbiamo a disposizione con
loro i nostri dreamer dobbiamo fare
innamorare del sapere e della conoscenza
fin da piccoli poi dobbiamo lavorare
sulle loro emozioni sull'autostima sulla
fiducia sul pensiero autonomo critico
in questo modo potranno crescere persone
nella loro interezza con tutte le
potenzialità per essere realmente
persone felici
bello il discorso e magari adesso sarete
portati a pensare che l'educazione di
qualità riguardi solo i bambini i
giovani i ragazzi non è così leggete
dietro di me si chiama lifelong learning
letteralmente significa l'apprendimento
per tutta la vita
cercherò di spiegarvelo in maniera molto
diretta e semplice sostanzialmente non
importa
siete e cosa state studiando che lavoro
state facendo e neppure quanti soldi
state guadagnando oggi perché l'unica
cosa che conta è che prima o poi non
basterà più
arriverà un momento in cui sarete
costretti costretti ad ampliare
costantemente il vostro bagaglio
personale del sapere costretti a
rimettervi in gioco e o scusate non ho
spento il telefono è arrivata una
notifica
ciao francesco il tuo sistema interno è
obsoleto in sono tre mesi che non apre
un libro aggiornati ma ovviamente vi sto
prendendo in giro non vivrete mai
un'esperienza di questo tipo perché non
ci sarà mai niente e nessuno che vi dirà
quando e come cambiare sarà
semplicemente il mondo che vi schizzerà
via davanti al naso alla velocità della
luce ad obbligare a farlo e quando ve ne
accorgerete
beh potrebbe essere troppo tardi sapete
perché perché il momento è qua ed è
adesso il treno sta partendo
ora vorrei farvi ragionare un secondo su
tutte queste considerazioni vi chiedo un
piccolo sforzo
so che l'ora non è delle migliori però
mi chiede di fare una riflessione tutti
insieme vi chiedo di pensare una persona
hanno persona a cui tenete molto
l'unica condizione che questa persona
deve essere nel periodo più importante
della sua vita quello della formazione
obbligatoria vi lascio qualche secondo
per pensarci ok magari non ci avete mai
riflettuto su ma questa persona
all'interno degli edifici scolastici per
cinque ore al giorno per settimane per
mesi per anni viene preparata ed educata
per un mondo che non esiste più per un
mondo che fa parte del passato e con un
metodo che fa parte del passato
pensate a quanto tempo perso a quanti
sogni infranti
ora pensate al suo futuro io sono
letteralmente terrorizzato da questo
scenario sono assolutamente convinto che
sia indispensabile rivoluzionare il
mondo delle due show e che bisogna farlo
in fretta per cercare di recuperare
almeno
in parte tutto il tempo che abbiamo
perso che stiamo continuando a perdere
però il mondo dei grandi al mondo i
nonni non importa non sembrano nemmeno
accorgersi di questo problema
per fortuna che che ci sono loro che ci
sono i bambini si perché loro non hanno
bisogno di spiegazioni loro lo sanno
benissimo per istinto almeno finché non
arriviamo noi adulti a distruggere
glielo quell'istinto che gioco e
divertimento ma non rima con felicità la
noia non è contemplata nel loro mondo
pensate invece a noi adulti per noi
adulti il gioco e al massimo un
passatempo tra un impegno importante
della vita è un altro
il gioco non può essere formativo il
gioco inutile non serve a nulla
signore e signori lasciatemelo dire noi
adulti dovremmo letteralmente essere
riprogrammati abbiamo l'assoluta
necessità di tornare a sognare con la
libertà mentale di un bambino e per
farlo c'è una sola e unica strada ridare
al gioco e al divertimento un ruolo
centrale nella nostra vita esattamente
come fanno tutti i giorni della loro i
bambini sì perché forse il segreto è
semplicemente tornare piccoli da grandi
oppure diventare grandi da piccoli
cosa significa questo sicuramente non
significa togliere il gioco i bambini ma
significa che fin da piccoli si possono
insegnare competenze complesse perché
non esistono competenze da grandi e
competenze da piccoli esistono
competenze e basta il ruolo di mentor
dovrebbe essere quello di aiutare i
bambini a scoprire le loro attitudini
senza programmi schemi preconfezionati
ma scegliendo insieme ogni giorno
insieme proprio insieme ai bambini cosa
fare
e possibile anche a 34 anni è difficile
ma si può fare in questo modo i bambini
potranno conoscere sperimentare anche
campi completamente
diversi in contemporanea grazie a giochi
multi disciplinari
in questo modo cresceranno cambieranno
idea di preferenze mille volte però in
tre cresceranno anche senza l'inutile
ansia delle verifiche dello studio ma
con la voglia di conoscere come parte
fondamentale della loro esistenza e poi
quando cresceranno dopo aver scoperto
molti campi diversi
bisognerà concentrarsi sulla scelta
sulla capacità di scegliere questo non
significa che devono completamente
eliminare dalla loro vita tutto il non
scelto ma significa che la scuola sta
dando loro gli strumenti per
concretizzare i sogni per essere
realmente felici e arrivare a
raggiungere i propri obiettivi
in questo modo tutti arriveranno al
diploma che avranno scoperto la loro
passione e poi avranno anche la giusta
determinazione per cominciare il loro
percorso da grandi con una
caratteristica in comune con tutti gli
altri il fatto di essere felici ogni
giorno della propria vita
si fa presto tuo vale a parlare di
passione legata felicità positività ma
forse non sai o forse volontariamente
ignori che il concetto originario di
passione è c'entra proprio poco con la
felicità e con la positività sì perché
in origine passione significava
sofferenza e ancora oggi troppe persone
considerano il lavoro come un esercizio
di vita obbligatorio come una passione
nel senso proprio di sofferenza cui non
possono porre rimedio
pochi pochissimi sono riusciti a
trasformare il lavoro la loro passione
qui si intesa come una naturale
inclinazione verso qualcosa
verrebbe da chiedersi perché perché
pochi si e tanti no qualcuno parla di
talento qualcun altro addirittura di
genialità altri ancora di tempismo
opportunità
io personalmente non sono d'accordo io
preferisco parlare di determinazione e
impegno costanti
perché dobbiamo metterci in testa che la
passione
non è un hobby una passione un fuoco che
arde dentro il nostro cuore e oggi è
possibile davvero trasformare una
passione in un lavoro questo processo
però chiaramente non è esente da
complicazioni necessita di tempo
edizione e tanti sacrifici ma
soprattutto una passione per poter
compiere questa straordinaria
trasformazione ha bisogno di un
individuo che sappia volare in alto
sulle sue reali e che abbia la capacità
di sognare senza mai porsi limiti
una volta raggiunta questa
trasformazione beh lì bisognerà
continuare ad alimentare quel fuoco che
arde farlo diventare un incendio e
credere che sia semplicemente è
possibile non basta quello è solo il
primo passo è cosa servirà allora direte
voi vi ricordate l'apprendimento
continuo proprio quello potremmo
sintetizzarlo con tre parole impara
disimpara impara è tutto qui chi non
avrà questa dinamica nelle proprie corde
potrà essere tranquillamente definito un
moderno analfabeta quindi dovrebbe
essere ormai chiaro a questo punto che
studiare è e sarà per sempre un obbligo
e lo sarà per tutta la vita ma
ricordatevi anche che farlo in maniera
divertente è e sarà sempre una vostra
scelta è possibile è davvero possibile
salvare il mondo attraverso l'educazione
perché l'educazione non è imparare fatti
e formule ma insegnare alle menti a
pensare per costruirsi il futuro
migliore possibile grazie
[Applauso]